the american music awards nominations
are out and we were in london this
morning with dua lipa just after she
announced some of the contenders
including herself don't show up
don't come dew is also performing at the
show which airs november 22nd on abc i'm
just so proud to be nominated and just
so grateful
i'm going to be filming mine from london
so um
we're going to we're going to create
something really really special
something exciting
something very
duo will be british against taylor swift
and lady gaga for favorite papa rock
female artist
but she's already got one celeb fan in
her corner
she's killing the game right now she's
doing really well uh you know i'm a fan
oh my god i uh this is the first time
i'm hearing about this
she's incredible she's a pop queen i'm
really kind of taken back by it that's
amazing
you know i feel i feel so grateful
[Music]
back in march dua lipa was the first pop
star to release new music during the
pandemic hoping to bring some light to a
dark time
it was like a form of escapism and
something that just made me want to have
lots of fun